more promising news tonight just off the
strip virgin hotels las vegas is
celebrating its complete
grand opening tonight the property first
opened its doors to guests back in march
arko mana is at its brand new beach club
with more on tonight's star-studded
event
this is a day virgin hotels las vegas
has been waiting for where everything on
property
is finally open that includes the elia
beach club here behind me
which is brand new it boasts this
beautiful pool and cabana area
all inspired by mykonos greece and to
celebrate all the excitement
we've got some big names here tonight
sir richard branson the founder of
virgin group kicking things off with the
champagne toast
and splash with some resort officials
and nevada governor steve sisilak
all highlighting the return of las vegas
this is all part of celebrating the full
opening of virgin hotels las vegas which
means all venues inside the resort are
now complete
this also kicks off what the property is
calling unstoppable weekend there are
big name artists performing later
tonight
including singer christina aguilera
chart topper flo rida and iconic dj
mix master mike you'll remember virgin
hotels las vegas which was formerly the
hard rock
first opened in march and now look
there's a brand new day club
and the party is just beginning
unstoppable weekend runs now
through sunday reporting at virgin
hotels las vegas orgomana 8 news now